noi
di solito strisce si è tornato la
settore del terrore non storico tutti i
creativi se non avete visto di altri
episodi andate a vedere dopo di questo è
uscito un nuovissimo ascensore con i
nuovi cattivi guardate vedete qui sono
tutti cattivi quale si capiteranno non
lo so sembra molto più paurosa questo
ascensore vedete c'è scritto ascensore
killer ieri elevator con i nuovissimi
cattivi non vedo l'ora di vedere quali
saranno è se vincerò io ho bisogno
abilitare in base ai punti che facciamo
cosa gr
ne sono rimasti abbastanza fermi quella
spesa vi dice che questo nuovo ascensore
molto rosea rispetto agli altri sapere a
voi che cattivo capiterebbe al piano
cliccato mi piace l'ultima cifra del
vostro mi piace corrisponde il cattivo
che capiterebbe a voi
pronti si prende tipo corni di tiago
subito guarda qua sopra andiamo
tutti eccoci siamo davvero al sensore
c'è scritto riesce a sopravvivere
vedremo rec e rec maastricht e non è un
cattivo non fa niente paura
che strano in che senso
aiuto dove da
vitale già mar eccolo
di nuovo dentro la settori ma non ci
credo che mi ha ripreso grata
non ci credo dopo sua volta mi offre
succedendo
seguendo ma sei uscito dall'ascensore sì
perché lui entrato dentro il senatore
delle monetine tanto
ok siamo sopravvissuti sono
sopravvissute alla nostra finestra
celato viviamo ma siamo al piano numero
49 sarà il cattivo a quanto già preso
tutte le monete
penetro mi sta inseguendo non ci credo
guarda ma perché ce l'ha con me o tale
il prodotto non posso perché si no
sapete come si chiama questo cattivo e
brutto
divenuto
meglio tornare nell'ascensore dovere non
lo trovo più tutti non trovi l'ascensore
un labirinto
ma si possa spuntare in queste porte no
ops ho attivato un allarme dopo non
posso scappare sono intrappolati ok sono
sopravvissute viva guardiamo solo
quattro o cinque o più punti di vitale
sapere dove sono i punti lì a fianco
il cattivo prima di vederlo secondo me
il pagliaccio qua perché ci sono vari
palloncini e cosa
secondo te secondo me
si
affacci oppure ho preso un belgio avete
visto il video in cui andiamo al
compleanno di pace se non lo avete visto
andate a vederlo perché abbiamo fatto
anche la vendetta di pace stato super di
vedere
bacci
aiuto che fai qui fregati spostati io
sto prendendo del belgio delle monetine
marinotti
io risolvo aiuto ma perché deve
inseguire sempre me questo mi ha fatto a
pezzi
stragelato finale e adesso rientro da
barba di nuovo ma perché sempre aperta
perché si seguono merda eccolo l'hanno
fatto a pezzi la vita dopo aiuto sono
state
un altro vita sono 210 punti però è
stato testa si sta recuperando
ma perché c'è sempre questa resa tra
inquinamento e tantissima speranza di
siamo siamo in un caffè cos'era lo vedo
blender ben
sopra forte qua non arriva lui sa che
buone e dice qualcuno invisibile guerra
si vede solo il cappello
[Musica]
guardate io raccolgo le monetine non
tenete lo occupato nomi è sfracellato
io torno in ambito nell'ascensore posso
dire splende vediamo se ti raggiungo io
sono bloccate aqua anno posso uscire
dove siete ecco ti va male
che succede dove è finito cosa mi dice
che è meglio scappare termico
l'assessore presto si dobbiamo da fare
penso che sia meno aspetta fammi
raccogliere il nostro paese ma dinamico
raggiunge lenovo perché sono sola sono
tutti morti parlo mi sono posto il
prossimo livello
vediamo e non riesco a passare
raccogliendo lavorative che succede
colomba ma
cos'è quella una bambola
che si può fare
qua c'è un laser è meglio non
noi anche molto attento quasi un bel
dove ha preso il floor ben attento devi
scappare da quelli così notti ok sto
andando a prendere il badge rosso non me
lo fa prendere aiuto si presa buio
quella mamma
troppo gli andò ponete
sempre contro di che vola c'è qualcuno
che riesce a volare
non credo
pure io no di nuovo che cosa c'è di
nuovo trend nel perché devo di nuovo i
capelli come hai fatto ad arrivare a 407
monete io sto raccogliendo tutte le
monete che trovo eppure non arriva
perché io vi sfracello meno volte di te
perché questa gente ti riprendono le
monete no
no penso che non fa i punti se ti
sfracelli se invece non ti sfracelli dai
più punti ecco smettere un'economia
preso studiando
devo tornare su un ascensore io sono del
bosco ho deciso io aspetto quando non
voglio andare da trender me no mi ha
fatto effetto di nuovo scritto che ora è
ancora più forte
nessuno sopravvive mai a splendere
sapremo lesionate ma c'è una scacchiera
penso che siamo
una casa di qualcuno è riuscito ma non
so come non lo so
che cos'è che il capo non capisco
jeff
aiuto ma velocissimo
mi metto quindi secondo majestic chi
ti ha freddo quasi ci è mancato poco la
presa per ma è velocissimo non lo vedo
più
aiuto te che si nasconde
va bene termine da settare già creata
volete dove sono le monete me siete
rubate tutte
prossimo cattivo che c'è scritto
amici fino alla fine
però quanti quanti si sono qua ma
dov'era
della moneta dall'altro ci sono le
monete niente lo dico a 12
ho trovato un posto
dove sono non lo so casa di ovviamente è
propaganda
wow preso un sacco di morello e se
provvisto prossimo a livello
già popolari
jason hanson il cattivo attento aiuto
che bello
che bello che questo ponticello ma sta
piovendo un tacco almeno presenza qui di
vettimo io ho preso jason ha risentito
non proprio
e torniamo presto ma penso che abbiamo
raccolte tutte le monete perché non ne
vedo più l atrio misura l'ascensore
[Musica]
mi hai superato con i punti come impatto
io sono stato attento non farmi prendere
esagera forse mai presa più monete di
maratta non ho fatto tutto io vediamo
chi è il prossimo cattivo e se questo
migliore aggiunge 10 mila mi piace fare
una seconda parte di questo sensore così
vedremo tutti gli altri cattivi e ma
perché non si apre
eccoci a sto già raccogliendo moneta
ma chi sei cattivo quando vestiamo ho
visto qualcuno
è lo spirito c'è scritto che ha visto lo
stesso insomma per un giardino
giapponese vedi e del giardino
giapponese storico di riciclaggio io
sono ritornato alla chat ora si vede
niente tutto questo no no no bene invece
guido nell'ascensore ebbene l'assessore
mi sembrava attrarre di imitare posto è
ancora vivo e animo mentre costato non
c'è superato avete un risultato avevo
preso altre momento è la vedo più
eccolo lo spirito capiamo troppo per
l'ascensione di questo settore
passati per un pieno
chi è in vantaggio salvataggio io o se
il 25 contro 11
nel frattempo che aspettiamo il prossimo
piano avete visto il video in cui
facciamo vedere alla nostra gattina e
giardino dorato tutte giardino super
super kalina dopo questo video andate a
vederlo perché troppo divertente e ora
vediamo che una casa degli slide
ma che cosa sta succedendo questo il
tema degli alien
ma non so come si fa ad andare giù qui
stavano facendo lo slime in aree asi è
una del trasportato si terni tra pro
riportato indietro tipo ma chi è cattivo
e non capisce mai un lievito canali la
61 prossimo livello bio
dove siamo e meglio non mi ruba la
monetina e una casa abbandonata
aiuto cosa
potevano caserme o sito di nero
eccolo colletto il nome capisco cosa
facciamo un fantasma a norma ce n'è uno
centro alla stanza e uno qui beh io
aspetto
perché per unire ai tutori quel settore
a me non l'ha visto sono rimasto
bloccato fermo nella scienza relativo
io
sopravvissuto anche io per un pene sono
risalita in vantaggio e vivrà prossimo
livello
ti ho trovato c'è scritto alla testa e
all'inizio trovato
nessuno ma non c'è un attimo per tipo
ciò che noi
beni che è il vetro rotto qua della
bassa della sedia a dondolo dove sta a
me ma velocissima la vedete laggiù è
piccolo e velocissima non siamo stati
tutti sfracellati da una bella e
difficilissima da battere rossi mio
livello
cos'è penso che sia
finance
e guarda caso è più vitale già morto
questi sono tutti nascosti
nell'ascensore
e freddi vista che viene a stando a chi
non l'ha sensore fa eco
stesso vitale
investito
mi sento e vedo che dietro
sei riuscito a sopravvivere ha visto
ultimo piano questa è la battaglia
decisiva vediamo se sopravviverò io ho
vitale severo più punti
vediamo che ci aspetta come ultimo
cattivo pentita ha bloccato l'ascensore
è un senso
non c'è più recente
che cosa ti è successo mi
metterò queste c
noi stiamo scendendo giù in cantina vivo
qui in questo posto stranissimo così un
ascensore non posso più entrare la fine
per me scp
087 stiamo continuando a scendere invece
qua sotto
quindi sappiamo chi ha vinto
dipende dai punti è lievitato sto
facendo un sacco di punti perché stanno
appoggiando tante monete sono
sopravvissuto guidi bene siccome mi ha
bloccato facciamo un altro lì ma mai un
tetto di prima benissimo o no beh questa
volta a scatto più veloce dietro di noi
contrarlo di una madre che prima vi ha
progettato
ma che cos'è un scpa esattamente adesso
numericamente voi che siete super
esperti e sapete sempre tutto vabbè
quindi qua bisogna solo scappare
l'ultima chiamo io sono al secondo
non tutto arrivando
provato no siamo sopravvissuti
ok dai questo è l'ultimo l'ultimo
livello vediamo chi si aspetta lo sembra
una casa va bene pubblico
dovere
ma siamo già stati
eccolo aiuto
si sta procedendo 5 doccia dopo vero
vitale aiuto no
è stato tutto vediamo quanti punti
abbiamo fatto allora io al novecento 41
punti e vitale 883 quindi stavo quasi
per superarli ma un beta yacht
che mi piace qui sotto per un altro
episodio e andate a vedere uno dei
nostri altri video in queste quattro
cappelline che il cup e su quello che
preferite buona visione
ciao